well jungle a prisoner jungle Cruz has
two janky animatronics though that like
like the hippopotamus is
like like they've never moved like that
in nature ever like in seeing this guy
moving fluidly I'd
[Music]
like all right best Disney ride go ooh
best Disney ride Space mountains
obviously up there uh I
like I like Peter Pan
oh man we knew you were gay oh the
pirate no you you you got you got to
have different categories right Kitty
rides Peter Pan is the best Kitty ride I
think I don't think I've ever done that
one are they I think they are no way I
think I like cars dude cars is that a
kitty ride cars is impressive cuz
there's like there's a story and then
you [__] go on the sideways thing I
like the Pirates and Buzz Light Year cuz
you can shoot have you been to the Toy
Story Midtown Mania that one's fun no it
sucks dude hey [__] [__] you dog were
you like were you like the carousel dude
there's this ball on a string and you
got to [__] like jerk off and to
shoot you know what I'm talking about
okay you know sounds like something that
you'd be pretty good at I I am pretty
good at wait what P like this he's like
but that's that's what you have to do
right high score high score high score I
think it's fun it's 3D interactive
okay Space Mountain is definitely up
there and what's the what's the rail oh
Indiana Jones Andy oh Big Thunder
Mountain yeah
big Big Thunder Mountain's sick cuz it
has a higher kill count bro I always
think about that [__] where you [__]
you dip your head I take it back it's
not Space Mountain it's California
screaming the one with the loop with the
Mickey Mouse that one the best one is
that in Disneyland or is it it's
California
Adventure hey the new Star Wars rides
are pretty Fire have you been to the the
one where they they're mean to you it's
like uh like the battle of the galactic
or whatever they're like they're in
character and they're like they call you
you Rebel scum and they're like mean to
you and [__] oh that's that one it's
like Indie but it's like Star Wars yeah
I've seen it but I hadn't been on it
that [__] is TI you should go I think
you would love it the set design is
pretty cool something Ryan would but I
don't like the new movies but it's fine
do you think the best ride is like a
classic one or like a newer one well one
Disney park guest got so enthusiastic
during It's a small world that they took
off all their clothes oh I heard about
this but he was in his underwear right
was he drunk yeah you can't be doing
that on a kid's no I think there was he
was on something or something like
people were like oh he's on a mushroom
trip he's on Salia we don't know dude
people on mushroom trips don't do that
my favorite thing was like the [__]
conservative pages that were just saying
he was just
liberal crazy liberal it's like that's
the only thing look at these liberals
this a Quick Clip but here's here's
homie it's a
small minimiz exited it for some
reason it's turning on you dude and
go oh no that guy is butt naked that's
it that's over well there was a lot of
clips of him like around I hope he
didn't break the ride he didn't they
shut it down for 3 hours though while
they dealt with that's one of my
favorite rides though is it well I
haven't been to Disneyland in like 10
years yeah it's very nostalgic but when
I was a kid um we had to do that that
was like the first thing to do cuz that
set off like the Disneyland feeling
right I had like a I had a whole system
like a DJ and it was going there then it
was going to Toontown to get the
autographs yep right and then getting
this feeling oh my oh yeah
God see look when you're a kid you
fantasize about doing this not naked
though is it funny when you hear the
song in different
languages he looks [__]
up we don't know what he's on or
anything like that what do you guys
think he's on I don't know man probably
Democratic beliefs yeah are there
professional CNN Disney tacklers huh I
wish there was professional Disney tack
they got their own jail they have Disney
cops and Disney secret police but they
never seem to do like anything when
shit's really hit in the fat his ass
like like the Toontown fight when there
was like two families like ding out
there was nobody there to do anything
but you know what it is though I was
watching the quartering and it's Biden's
America it's all adjacent dude it's all
right next to each other hey you know
what dang dude but I it is a sucky thing
for your kid to have to see that like
how do you explain like if ta was like
what's he doing what's your explanation
there's a I'm like some people are just
crazy was he that's what I say well
taica sees his dad in his underwear like
all the time dancing outside the same
[__] it's like he's doing what you're
doing Dad was he there by himself or
like is there a backstory cuz I saw this
everywhere and all nobody knows dude he
looks like he's by himself nobody wants
to claim him no one wants to yeah he
came with friends but after they they
saw what he did they're like all right
let's get out of here it's funny like to
hear all the people's different angles
and how they all keep trying to tell him
to stop it's like he's not going to stop
like he's like come on man don't I just
need some reason in my life I need
someone to tell me what what I'm doing
wrong like as it he's so [__] high
though but if he was doing that on the
jungle cruise right nobody would bat and
KN oh it's a part of the thing yeah it's
mowgly yeah what rides could he have
done this Indiana Jones yep yep maybe
Pirates well jungle a prisoner jungle
Cruz has two janky animatronics though
that shit's like [__] like the
hippopotamus is
like like they've never moved like that
in nature ever like can seeing this guy
moving fluidly I'd like should they
start having Chuck-E-Cheese rules for
Disneyland like fames only if you don't
have a kid you can't come in and then
like oh CH has that rule yeah but then
no college kids could come any why would
you want them at Disneyland a lot of
people go to Disneyland by themselves yo
yeah that's weird lot of people you
think that's weird I think that's weird
weird they don't got friends and [__]
probably dog well cuz it's a place where
there's children it's a cult dude
Disney's a cult I got a buddy who goes
to movies alone and I'm always like
that's weird yeah I do that that's weird
that is weird what was the last movie
you saw by yourself we do that for ROM
like going to the restaurant alone I
watched the boy in the Heron by myself
at 400 p.m. nobody's in the theater and
I'm just going in there and I'm chilling
dude it's like so relaxing was a good
time yeah it was great it was a great
movie cuz I could focus more when
there's yeah cuz there's no minorities
talking yeah that's why that's why he's
like avoiding all the people of color
that talk during movies it's cheaper in
the daytime and like I don't know it's
just a nicer like experience when you're
just going by yourself but would you go
to Disneyland by yourself huh hell no
dude A lot of people do go by themselves
you're all right that's weird I hate
Disneyland did I tell you guys how much
I hate Disneyland no why why do you hate
it bro I have beef with Disneyland you
grew up you wait he used to work at
Disneyland that's why oh we were so as
porotic we were hired as like temporary
employ okay for the event I thought you
like at the b car we have this whole
beef with them where we performed like
every weekend for Electronica which is
like their Tron theme at Disney
California so the whole routine is like
they take us to the back lot and we have
this employee area where it looks like
Bungalows and stuff it's like dead as
[__] and then they walk us through there
to the inside of the park and it's like
wow it's so colorful so you the
background of of where Disneyland is or
California it's like it looks super
corporate it's like very like grayed out
and then when you go into the park it's
all like such a big contrast right so we
performed at the thing like every
weekend and there was this one time
where we brought our girlfriends and
they were totally cool with that like
you just need a little sticker to get
into the back employ area and so in
California Adventure you can buy drinks
you can walk around with drinks and
they're they're cool with that right and
so the girlfriends had drinks we didn't
have any drinks we had just got done
performing and we all walked backstage
together and then the girls accidentally
brought the drinks back to the employee
area which they're not supposed to do
but we didn't know that cuz we you know
we were just like whatever and the
security guy that was there didn't stop
them he was just like whatever they walk
through and then um once one of the
Disney employees saw that there was
alcohol on our table when we were like
already done with our show we're
changing they're like oh you can't have
that here oh no I have to call my
Superior and then the superior guy
came and then he got super mad cuz he
thought we were the ones that were
drinking on the job which is like so
they imagined a different scenario yeah
so it's it's like immediate termination
they like blacklisted us and we're like
what the [__] like we're trying to
explain to them that we didn't know and
we but they think you're a bunch of liar
they thought we were drinking like as we
were performing so they so because the
guy didn't want to look bad at doing his
job because realistically the security
guy [__] up he's not supposed to allow
anybody with drinks back there but he
[__] up but I don't think Disney wants
to take it like it sounds like all the
staff wanted to blame it on you so none
of and we didn't even drink either so
that's the crazy thing so and you don't
even really have girlfriends you guys
like virgins and [__] yeah exactly
[__] nerds really straight edge
forever yeah but after that happened I
saw how like nobody at Disney wanted to
take blame for something that I think
that they [__] up on and so it made me
go like dude there's some [__] up [__]
going on in in like back there where I'm
like I never want to go to Disneyland
unless it's like with someone new or
whatever and I never want to work for
Disney like ever damn that sucks that
that Su D cuz that's just like one or
two departments yeah yeah it's just
weird how they don't treat you like like
oh let's try to hear you out like
instead it's like no we're not going to
take blame for this it's like you [__]
[__] up and we're going to so from
that moment you guys just got fired and
the Tron show had to shut down just from
that yeah like well I mean they could
have got like Jaa walkies our act got
cut but the laser guy still did his
thing cuz there was laser guy yeah it
was like this whole show it was like
points at everybody dude working for
Disney versus going to Disneyland two
completely different experiences I heard
a lot of people working for them say hm
not a great company I know a lot of
people don't like working for them
that's like Amazon too right buying
things off of Amazon versus working for
Amazon horrible I technically worked for
dis dude it felt like an evil
Corporation dude yeah I technically
worked for them because they bought
Maker Studios and then like I was
working there so it was really weird but
they definitely um didn't really care
about us did you did you get to see Bob
Iger and go [__] you [__] I didn't say
[__] you cuz he was buying the company
at the time and that would been really
weird did he just get called out for
something recently on Twitter or no it
was Elon he was saying [__] you Bob AER
[__] off you try to extort me dude I'm
telling you dude they're evil man this
shit's crazy I never want to buy into
that Disney you know but evil companies
have the best products dude they do like
Amazon dude that's the best thing
Disneyland is the best thing like if
they told me in-n-out's evil I'm like of
course it's
delicious why wouldn't they be makes
sense wouldn't be able to afford [__] in
this world I'm not a big Bill Gates guy
cuz he like put a lot of people out of
business in the 90s like like and he
loved it and like [__] was an [__]
you love windows but I use PC nonstop
like I'm a total hypocrite cuz didn't he
like something with Xerox or something
like that oh dude I hate how evil you
are and how you make life so exible for
the poorest people there's a balance so
what happened with the experience with
Disney and uh and maker oh um I mean it
was it was like basically they slowly
swallowed maker like a snake swallowing
a a [__]
crocodile but in a good way no and then
the snake like basically explodes when
the crocodile falls out dead that's
basically what happened they didn't know
what to do s like dise they didn't know
what to do with it they basically it it
was a fugazi basically and they didn't
realize it well we'll find out more in
your book right
[Music]
yeah